I have turned one hundred thousand worlds to
dust looking for those who robbed me of my glory
i will stride across their bones
and all of existence shall be mine
this world is divided too separate to be one
no protectors here
this world will fall
i have turned 100 000 worlds to dust
and when this world is scorched
of existence shall be mine.
the whole world is mourninggrieving over a symbol let's hope you're not too late it's like they were afraid of
flyson it's time i made a promise on his grave
you will help them accomplish wonders
they wanted me back for a reason
i need to find out why
evil does not sleep it waits something
is coming back to the dark ages the devil
in his army you know the world is broken
this is the only way
I watched your island burn. Show him your fear. We have no fear.
They said the age of heroes would never come
again don't engage alone we do this together
whatever happened to you you have gifts now
everything breaks victor i can't wait to see
what you can pick in the world of ones and zeroes
you are the absolute master these boxes are
get inside you and find your weaknesses and
your fears take your place among the brave ones
i'm not broken and i'm not alone
I want you to listen to me barry because
i mean this i'm putting together a team of
people with special abilities you can be
whatever you want to be i can't sit here
and watch you run in place you have to
run faster than you've ever attempted
you're brilliant man absolute best of the best
make your own future your
own future make your own past
it's all right now
you can turn your back on the world forever
above or below thousands of years since our people
spoke the born of beloved queen Atlanna I need
warriors you can't escape the time has come
take up your mother's trident this is a bad idea
fighting the devil in his army in hell
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
justice league snyder cut trailer zack snyder's
been dropping a whole bunch of new clips so we'll
break it all down there's a bunch of easter eggs
and the movie is dropping next week unless you
were trying to watch tom and jerry just a couple
days ago then you probably got to see it a couple
days early i'll explain what was going on with
that too for everybody that wondered why the movie
leaked out just a couple days ago but be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i'll be doing a
bunch of videos for it next week it's going to be
over four hours long so there's going to be a lot
of stuff to talk about between that and falcon
and winter soldier episodes dropping but just to
explain what happened with the snyder cut leak a
couple days ago it wasn't quite as big a deal as
people made it out to be it was just inside the
united states a bunch of people reported that when
they were trying to watch tom and jerry on hbo max
it would queue up the snyder cut so they were
like wow you know i clicked on tom and jerry
and wound up watching a pretty decent movie
everyone was posting all their memes it was
more of a technical error just some person behind
the scenes fixed the bug within a couple hours so
the call was coming from inside the building so it
wasn't like some malicious hack or anything like
that it wasn't like someone was trying to take
it from their servers it was just an accidental
bug that they fixed pretty quickly but because the
movie was over four hours long and they said they
fixed it really quickly i don't think that anybody
actually got to watch the entire version of the
movie but if you saw people posting about this
like hey i'm watching the snyder cut right now
that was actually a real thing it really did
happen but just starting with the new footage
you start with the steppenwolf scenes you get a
much better look at him in the actual movie and a
lot of voice over dialogue from him he sounds very
different than he sounded during the theatrical
cut but there's also a brand new dark side scene
with new dark side voiceover so you get to hear
more of what he actually sounds like in the film
but the first voice over is steppenwolf's speech
the full version of his no lanterns no kryptonians
no protector speech just talking about how the
modern world has become divided setting the stage
for the justice league to come together then you
see the parademons dragging the atlanteans
out of the water onto dry land the way the
aquaman movie explained that is that only special
atlanteans like the royalty were actually able to
breathe normally on land just because of their
unique biology that was somehow different from
normal atlanteans so if you drug one of them
onto land you'd be suffocating them basically
but mostly steppenwolf and darkseid convert
their defeated enemies into more parademons
to just keep expanding their army it's a very game
of thrones night king scenario like where he kills
your troops then raises them back up as his own
undead soldiers growing his army exponentially
over time as you keep trying to fight them then
you see steppenwolf squaring off with wonder
woman inside the cooling tower with a giant axe
weapon then another scene of him cracking the
earth i believe this is back on themyscira leaving
that cool symbol burned into the ground and him
using that mother box he took from the amazons to
have a cosmic zoom call with darkseid who's still
back on apocalypse for darkseid then we get that
new dark side voiceover dialogue i have turned
a hundred thousand worlds to dust and when this
world is scorched all of existence shall be mine
with a bunch of new scenes that dark side war
flashback scene i'm not sure if darkseid's
speech is coming during that actual flashback
scene or if the speech is from present day when
he's preparing to come back to earth himself to
conquer it that all leads up to the events of
that nightmare alternate future in the flashbacks
he's still supposed to be ooxas he hasn't taken
the dark side name yet and i'm assuming that also
means that he hasn't taken the full omega force
like that's why you don't see him using his omega
beams when he's fighting all these combined armies
but he does have the omega symbol in his chest
upside down i guess just foreshadowing that future
what he's talking about during that speech though
why earth is the key to him conquering the rest
of the universe i think is more to do with him
getting the three mother boxes back because those
three ones just based on my understanding of the
information that they're presenting in the movie
are the only ones in existence and he can't just
create more mother boxes and i believe they're
supposed to be the key to the anti-life equation
and the anti-life equation is really what his end
game level power up is that'll allow him to take
over the entire universe in one fell swoop it's
like thanos during avengers infinity war before he
acquired the infinity stones he spent hundreds and
hundreds of years of his very long lifespan just
flying around the universe from planet to planet
conquering them balancing them quote unquote so
to speak that's what the infinity gauntlet was for
giving him that boss level upgrade that allowed
him to do it with a single snap of his fingers
so for darkseid in the dc universe that's
the mother boxes in the anti-life equation
then there's the other new scene of what
seems like dark side where you see his hand
on superman while he's kneeling down so this might
be from the nightmare flash forward scenes because
superman is wearing the black costume or it could
be steppenwolf in present day when he first comes
back but the whole thing with the nightmare
timeline is that superman has been emceed by
the anti-life equation because lois lane has died
and she was sort of his connection to humanity so
once he loses that it's much easier for darkseid
to turn him then you have the other new scene of
superman when he first comes back returning
to the fortress of solitude kryptonian ship
to grab a new suit and you see all the different
versions there's actually way more than we've seen
in the other deleted scenes there's the kryptonian
warframe suit from the comics the footage is kind
of low resolution and blurry but this armor in
the back here on the left looks like it's the
same armor that jor-el wore during man of steel
like just traditional kryptonian armor from the
house of l then this other new armor on the right
seems like it's either zod's armor that he's just
taken into custody or similar armor azad was
wearing more militaristic kryptonian armor
then you have the classic blue suit and then they
just stop short of him grabbing the black suit
but you see him step through the doorway later
wearing the black suit then you have the scene
of wonder woman grabbing the warning arrow that
hippolyta fired from themyscira when steppenwolf
attacked the voice over dialogue of steppenwolf
taunting her later in the movie i watched your
island burn then you get the new cyborg scene
of him seeing visions of himself and his family
before his accident the background also looks kind
of post-apocalyptic like it's the nightmare future
timeline then there's a bunch of new flash scenes
so you get all the voice over from his father and
from a couple other characters like batman talking
about him running faster than he's ever run before
as he's saving iris west and the footage
of him later in the movie when he's running
into the speed force you get all this dialogue
about him altering the future altering the past
that's just a reference to flashpoint in his time
travel abilities there's also the scene of him in
the nightmare timeline wearing his future armor
like with a special faceplate that you saw during
batman v superman we even see deathstroke in that
scene too with the big mohawk then you get the
new scene of aquaman and atlantis going to the
statue of king atlan to take his suit of armor
and the voice over from volko telling him to take
up his mother's trident there were actually a lot
of vulcos scenes that we'll see in the snyder
cut that were deleted out of the theatrical cut
but i've already done a video for the new martian
manhunter scene in that last big trailer in the
batman version of this trailer so i'll put a
link for that in the description but just a big
reminder the snyder cut is releasing next week
i'll do a video for it on the day probably for
the new version of the ending just explaining
what's different what the easter eggs are
and what would have happened in the sequels had
zack snyder made them they basically reveal the
entire plot of what justice league 2 in justice
league 3 would have been because it would have
been three justice league movies a full trilogy
like you kind of expect so there'll be all kinds
of videos about that but here's the thing falcon
in winter soldier episode 1 is releasing the day
after the snyder cut so i'll be doing videos for
all those things what'll probably happen is i'll
just go back and forth between falcon and winter
soldier videos in the justice league snyder cut
videos till i get through all the stuff but if
you spotted any big easter eggs in this that i
didn't talk about in the video or in my other
previous trailer videos just write them below
in the comments and i know the flash tv show is
back and i haven't done videos about that yet
i'm waiting for them to get to the new storyline
so eventually i will probably do a flash tv show
video but probably not for a couple weeks
while you wait for everything everyone
click here for that brand new falcon and winter
soldier trailer with the doctor strange scene
and click here for my full Wandavision episode
9 finale video in all my Wandavision episodes
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!